problema número 177 el contador de una
compañía estima que las tarifas aéreas
para el próximo año para viajes menores
a 1.000 kilómetros aumentará un 20% y
para todos los demás viajes de negocios
se incrementará un 10% este año las
tarifas de todos los viajes de menos de
1000 kilómetros fue un total de nueve
mil novecientos y las tarifas de todos
los demás viajes fue de 13.000 si se
hicieron la misma cantidad de viajes el
próximo año cuánto se gastaría en
tarifas aéreas al año bueno mi problema
con esto es que dice la misma cantidad
de viajes lo que me hace pensar que la
cantidad de vuelos menores a mil
kilómetros y el resto de los viajes se
mantienen igual también
hagamos lo que creo que nos piden
calculamos el aumento del 20% de 9.900
este aumento lo vamos a poner como 1.2
y vamos a hacer la operación acá 9900
por 1.2
esto es igual 2 por 0 0 2 por 0 0 9 por
218 llevamos 19 por 2 18 119 y esto por
100 99 lo sumamos 0 0 89 9 18 llevamos
19 más 110 más 111 y con un espacio
después del punto decimal lo recorremos
aquí y nos queda 11.880 más esto más el
10% de lo que va a aumentar los otros
viajes 1.1 en 10 por ciento por la otra
cantidad de los viajes que fue de 13 mil
13.000
y ahora vamos a hacer esa operación
13.000 por 1.11 13000
por 1 punto 11 0 031 aquí también
multiplicamos por 10 031 sumamos
00 03 41 y tenemos el punto 1 un lugar
decimal acá y nos queda 14.300 o sea
esto de aquí es 11.880 11.880
más esto de aquí que acabamos de
encontrar es 14 mil 314 mil trescientos
y la suma de esto es igual a cero 88 más
311 llevamos una 415 más unas 6 y 112
de 6.180 esto es lo que va a aumentar y
es mi opción b siguiente problema
problema número 178 si x estrellas es
igual a x x menos 2 por la suma de x más
100 para todos los enteros x 100 que es
igual 2 estrella menos 3
una sustitución de patrones donde veamos
x vamos a poner 2 y donde veamos
pondremos menos 3
estrella
-3 va a ser igual aquí hay una equis
pongo un 2 hay una y pongo un menos 3 -
2 aquí hay una equis pongo dos más aquí
hay una y pongo menos 3
cierro aquí y ahora simplificó esto esto
igual 2 x menos 3 es igual a menos 6
menos
2 por 242 por menos 3 es menos 6
esto es igual a menos 64 24 menos por
menos es más
6 - 66 seba y esto me queda igual a
menos 4 que es mi opción c siguiente
problema
no muestro en esta tabla nombre del club
número de estudiantes esta tabla muestra
los estudiantes en tres clubes escolares
aunque ninguna estudiante está en los
tres clubes 10 están en ajedrez y teatro
5 están en ajedrez y matemáticas y seis
están en teatro y matemáticas nos
preguntan cuántos estudiantes diferentes
están en los tres clubes vamos a hacer
un diagrama tenemos aquí
vamos a escribir que estos son 40
estudiantes que están en el club de
ajedrez ajedrez
aquí en otro color voy a dibujar los
estudiantes que están en el club
de teatro teatro
teatro
y aquí hay 30 estudiantes
y además voy a tener otro club que lo
voy a dibujar con color naranja y esto
lo voy a dibujar a mano porque no creo
que la herramienta me permite hacer lo
que quiero aquí voy a dibujar
lo que es
el club de matemáticas
te lo abre vía así que tiene 25
estudiantes
todos los integrantes de cada club
cuántas veces sumaríamos los que se
intersectan si sumamos
40 30 40
+ 30 que son los de ajedrez y teatro
estaríamos sumando aquí primero con los
40 estaríamos sumando está una vez y al
sumar los 30 estaríamos sumando esta
intersección otra vez aquí los 10 que
están en ajedrez y teatro los estaríamos
sumando dos veces así que tenemos que
restar 10 una vez 40 más 30 menos 10
estos serán los estudiantes de los
clubes de ajedrez y teatro esto es igual
a 40 más 30 y 70 menos 10 60 ahora
veamos si a estos 60 le sumamos 25
estudiantes de matemáticas estaremos
sumando dos veces los seis que están en
teatro y matemáticas los de aquí
y dos veces los que están en ajedrez y
matemática estos de aquí que son cinco
aquí estuviéramos sumando seis dos veces
y aquí cinco dos veces así que tenemos
que restar a esta suma de 60 más 25 del
club total de matemáticas tenemos que
restarle 6 y restarle 5 que son los que
se duplican así que todo esto va a ser
igual a 85 menos 11
igual a 74 esta es la opción c siguiente
problema problema número 180 en una
encuesta nacional se entrevistaron n
personas en la primera pregunta de la
cena de personas que se entrevistaron en
la primera pregunta primera pregunta
cuarto
respondió que sí y de estos que
respondieron que si una tercera parte
respondió que sí a la segunda pregunta
la segunda pregunta
de las siguientes expresiones cual
muestra la cantidad de personas que
respondieron no a cualquiera de las
preguntas si tenemos que un cuarto
respondió que sí pues de los n tres
cuartos
respondieron que no y de estos de los
que sí respondieron a la segunda
pregunta también que sí tenemos que el
complemento de un tercio es dos tercios
que respondieron que no dos tercios de
un cuarto dos tercios de un cuarto es
esto lo simplificamos esto es uno esto
es dos
queda uno por uno 13 por 26 un sexto
estos dijeron que si a la primera
pregunta y no a la segunda si sumamos
este sexto más los tres cuartos que
dijeron que no a la pregunta primera
será un sexto más tres cuartos
más tres cuartos igual al común
denominador 12 6 por 2 12 2 por 12 más 3
por 4 12 3 por 3 9 igual a 11 12 a 2 de
mi población m que es la opción
y que con esto terminamos este vídeo nos
vemos en el siguiente